welcome back you're watching Sky News
tonight and over the next half an hour
we're going to be answering some of your
questions about the war in Ukraine and
how the recent escalation may have
changed the situation I'm joined by the
defense and security analyst Professor
Michael Clarke who will attempt to
answer all your questions some great
questions aren't there Michael Let's uh
take my Marcus's to start with first of
all Marcus asks this do you think
Ukraine can win this War and what will
be a likely solution to bringing an end
to the conflict well in terms of what's
happening on the ground we've seen these
gains over the last few weeks and months
by you gray yes it's plausible now that
Ukraine can I would I wouldn't use the
phrase win the war they can Prevail
militarily which is to say they are
capable of pushing the Russians back to
where they were before the 24th of
February in terms of the territorial
gains maybe going further the ukrainians
certainly say they're going to keep on
going until they get all of their
territory back going to 2014 which would
include Crimea well we'll see about that
but yes can they do it yes will they do
it I don't know but they are capable of
doing it but that is only the this part
of the struggle this is the second war
right the first war was 2014 the first
Russian Ukrainian War this is the second
year Russian UK Ukrainian War my feeling
is that there will be maybe an extra
ceasefire
which in which the ukrainians will be
better placed than we used to think and
that ceasefire will be unstable it'll
break down and be a third war and then
the season final fourth wall we're
dealing here with an existential
struggle because Russian not just Putin
the Russian establishment thinks that
Ukraine has no right to exist and
they'll go on they won't change that
mindset they won't change them short
term so this is likely to be a
generational struggle so that's let's
say it's going to last 30 40 50 years
wow so the second part of Marcus's
question what's a likely solution to
bringing an end to the conflict you're
saying it's going to be a forever
conflict well it's a forever conflict
until something changes in European
security or Russia fairly fundamentally
but UK can the ukrainians win back their
territory yes but they'll have to live
in an armed peace with a neighbor 10
times their size that doesn't birth them
any good will and if there is a third
war it'll be probably tougher than this
second war because by then both of them
will have armed themselves up so this is
the beginning of a completely new era in
European security well we've got some
questions uh later on I know from people
asking about that change potential
change you mentioned there might happen
in Russia but let's take Rick's question
next uh Rick asked this we've heard a
lot about deficiencies in the Russian
Logistics including few
once the ground has frozen hard again
how successful do you think Ukrainian
forces will be in further
counter-attacks during the winter period
as the saying goes winter is coming yes
and the the Russians are clearly playing
for time now because they're losing in
two big two major fronts and may start
to lose on a third front as well south
of Zuppa Asia I'm not sure about that
but that's possible they're playing for
time waiting for the winter because in
the winter it's not that fighting stops
but I mean Winter's miserable for
everybody particularly these sorts of
winters which are very cold and pretty
can be very brutal but it's easier to be
on the defensive than on the offensive
in a winter because you've just got to
stay put in wherever you are whereas if
you're on the offensive you've got to
keep moving around you your vehicles
have got to keep moving and they've got
to keep completely
um properly maintained and so on so it's
it's harder to run an offensive during
the winter although the hard ground is
good for tanks and armored vehicles they
don't sink into the mud which is what is
happening at the moment because this is
the the rainy season now in Ukraine on
balance it's better to be defending than
attacking during the winter and so the
Russians are playing for winter they're
digging in and then next year with this
mobilization they're going to come back
with a big second offensive the other
side of the winter okay well the
follow-on question here from Dave
Langdon uh about the situation you
mentioned they're about digging in uh
Dave asked this are we likely to see a
Siege situation like the Battle of
Stalingrad this winter and if so is it
possible that Russian troops might
suffer from starvation you talk about
digging in but you can get surrounded
somewhere like Kershaw or something like
that yes I mean that's plausible I mean
nothing is as bad as Stalingrad I mean
that was that was the greatest most
brutal Battle of the 20th century I
think certainly of the second world war
um and I doubt of it would be like that
and uh they you know the Russians can
always get food through I mean we talk
about Russian suffering from starvation
they're already suffering from pretty
poor food and not much of it because
Russian Logistics are so bad but yes a
series of seizures where the Russians
are holding against a Ukrainian
offensive that's going more slowly
during the winter I would foresee that
happening because the ukrainians have
really got their tails up now they've
prepared these two offensives one in the
towards the donbass in luhansk now and
the other one in the cursing region they
they worked on them for a long time they
planned them with the Americans and the
Brits very carefully they wargame them
out and they're now they're pursuing
them really very cleverly now they may
not go as quickly in the future as
they've gone in the last month or two
but I suspect that the Russians will be
glad to see the other side of the winter
when they've got more troops will then
who will then be better trained starting
to arrive at the Battlefront you
mentioned more troops there that partial
mobilization where we've got a question
from Jackie which touches on the
potential that there might be even more
uh Jackie asking what implications is
there likely to be now that Belarus has
teamed up with Russia well of course has
always teamed up with Russia is it
inevitable we are heading for World War
III but could there be more troops than
Belarusian forces coming from the north
now Jackie don't worry about that um I
mean Belarus is a very it's a very small
country it's a big country territorially
but it's less than 10 million people uh
it's it's armed forces are an unknown
quantity but they're very weak
um they're about 30 000.
um and most analysts would say they
can't really put more than about 15 000
troops into the field because most of
them are not actually active military
most of the time even though they're on
the books and if if the belarusians had
to do something really quick like by the
end of next week
um they could not produce more than six
or seven thousand troops
um so they're a very small Force the
Russians are putting with them it seems
some of their under strength units that
have been withdrawn from the battle and
someone from the 20th combined arms Army
are going for joint exercises with the
belarusians
um now joint exercises mean whatever you
want it to mean but I think that you
know the chance of a a serious Force
being formed in Belarus is not great
what they're trying to do by talking
about these joint operations and joint
exercises is worry the ukrainians into
thinking that they might be able to open
a third front up on the north west of
Ukraine to distract Ukrainian offensives
down in the uh down towards the south of
the country in the donbass around
Kirsten at the moment the ukrainians
keep just Reserve forces screening the
Belarusian border if they had to keep
some of the better forces there they're
more ready forces that would be that
would be a nuisance I mean that would
complicate their life but I don't think
they worry too much about it and the
ukrainians are very clear-eyed about
this they're watching very carefully and
they're not terribly bothered at the
moment by everything that's been said
okay let's uh get to uh touched on
earlier the situation in Russia itself
I'm going to ask two questions because
they're kind of linked at the same time
too this initially from Mark saying what
is Putin's way out of this wall without
him losing face it has to end somehow uh
Carl in asking the question one way it
might and do you think a coup against
Putin is a realistic possibility well
you know we it's hard to judge isn't it
the impact of you know the resistance
we've seen within Russia particularly to
this conscription I mean I would say you
know nobody knows what's going to happen
but a coup is an entirely realistic
possibility at some point but we just
don't know when because I've always
argued I mean when you and I've been
talking in previous weeks the Putin is
finished but how long it will take for
him to finish whether he will go in a
matter of months in a sudden reversal of
Fortune within the Kremlin or whether
it'll be two or three years but he's
taking Russia nowhere in this crisis and
things are getting worse now
interestingly this week American
intelligence reported that they they
knew who it was in the Kremlin who is
now opposing Putin and that intelligence
report was given to the president and we
don't know who the what the name is the
Washington Post reported it Faithfully
as the as an American intelligence
report re-series report
um and President Biden was told who it
is in the crime who's seriously opposing
Putin now we can guess but you know we'd
all be sort of casting around but I mean
the people who matter in the Kremlin is
a petrushchev who is and who he's worse
than Putin in terms of his views he's
the chairman of the National Security
Council um in kirienko who's his Deputy
Chief of Staff his personal chief of
staff lavrov is very powerful
um somewhere if there is opposition it's
it's likely to come from the military in
the security service so it's that even
more hardliners that more hard lines
yeah he's being he's been a saved by
people who don't like the war who are
unhappy about it and people who actually
think he's too soft on the wall and so
it's possible that he'll be removed by
people who want to fight this war
differently so you know Putin being
removed is not necessarily going to end
this war at all it may actually take it
into a new phase and we've just got to
face that possibility but yes a coup is
entirely plausible well let's talk about
this phase that we seem to move into
yesterday with Russia firing those
missiles deep into Ukraine and at
civilian targets as well and Gary asks
this why is Russia able to fire
long-range missiles into Ukraine but
Ukraine cannot return long-range
missiles presumably he means into parts
of Russia is that that's a decision
taken by Ukraine there's two reasons one
is that the ukrainians don't have them
uh long-range missiles or long enough
range and the Russians do and secondly
even if they do have them or do get them
and I think they they do I I think they
do have some
um and that's a different story but the
Americans won't either confirm or deny
that the ukrainians may have these
attacker missiles which is this Army
tactical uh missile itself which is very
long range very good Warhead
um longer range that you can use them on
a multiple launch rocket system usually
the mlrs are systems and will take
either 6 or 12 smaller Rockets with a
range of 50 or 60 miles the atacums I've
got a range of 180 miles and I'll carry
a 500 pound Warheads so those are pretty
big things when you look at what the
ukrainians have achieved in Crimea the
suspicion is that they've got some and
they may have got them via the United
from the US via Poland or Romania or
even turkey who have been supplied with
these things we don't know that's just a
speculation but in general the
ukrainians don't have long-range
missiles and if they did have them they
almost certainly won't Target Russian
territory directly because it's very
important that is that this conflict is
not seen as an attack on Russia this
whole war is about liberating Ukraine
from unprovoked aggression it's not
about attacking Russia it's a bit like
you think of the Gulf War in 1991 the
famous Gulf War against Saddam Hussein
it was all about liberating Kuwait a lot
of people said oh carry on to Baghdad
you know carry on we've we've completely
you know we've whipped the Iraqis now
Karen and President Bush senior said no
no this was only ever about liberating
Kuwait we are not going to try and bring
down Saddam saying that's what he said
in 1991. same thing here if the
ukrainians started to attack Russian
territory directly obviously then it
would diminish the support we feel
because then it would be interrupted in
Russia is it really is an attack on
Russian Homeland and it isn't let's talk
about NATO now uh this one from Harry
I'm going to ask a second one also about
NATO from Andy as well so let's look at
both these questions Harry's first at
what point would NATO get directly
involved in the conflicts and Andy then
posing a potential scenario I suppose
what would be the consequence if any of
Russia's missiles Landing in NATO
territory even by accident well we know
NATO is deeply involved yeah in this
conflict in terms of Weaponry training
Logistics everything but not actually
business on the ground and that's one of
the red lines which both sides have
respected and understand that the NATO
troops and Russian troops or forces
should not come into direct contact and
the Russians seem to know that very
clearly and we know it very clearly but
but short of that red line we're all
moving towards it and in reality of
course NATO keeps cost Crossing
thresholds we keep supplying Ukraine
with more potent Weaponry because as
this conflict goes on as the Russians
get more outrageous and as the war
crimes build up day after day after day
you know shelling of Civilian areas so
the the
um reluctance of NATO members and
governments in NATO to supply potent
weapons kind of evaporates and so as
again as you and I have spoken about it
previously I think NATO is crossing
thresholds all the time in terms of what
it's going to do what about if Russia
attacked some let's say an arms Depot or
a training center in a NATO country if
it was deliberate there would be a
response for sure because NATO has said
stoltenberg the NATO Secretary General
said you've been backed up by Biden to
say not an inch every inch of NATO
territory is sacred to Nato if it was an
accident we I suspect we'd make a big
fuss and we'd protest but if we
suspected it wasn't an accident there
would be a response I'm sure about that
oh my goodness me uh David asked this do
you think this is um perhaps along the
lines of a question we've already had
but do you think that Ukraine may start
tit-for-tat strikes against civilian
Targets in Russia and I know I was
talking yesterday to a former prime
minister who suggested that perhaps
Ukraine should try that and you know
this is the way that some third world
wars start presuming it is and I I think
it would be you know for the reasons
that we've already mentioned it would be
self-defeating for Ukraine to do that
um because you know attacking civilian
targets just confirms the civilian
population in hatred for who is
attacking them
civilians civilian morale does not break
by civilian targets being attacked I
mean it was the case in the second world
war it was a case in other Wars around
the world if you're a tax civilian
targets the civilians don't crack they
get more determined generally speaking
um and it would destroy uh Ukraine's
very good moral position I mean you know
everybody wants to help Ukraine
everybody who respects the position
everybody in the west respects their
position that would be undermined if
they seem deliberately to attack
civilian targets because the Western Way
of warfare is that we do not I promise
you we do not deliberately attack
civilian targets civilians sometimes get
killed and injured by Western action but
I I again I can promise you it has never
ever deliberate it is always some
combination of accidents or or
misunderstandings or whatever it might
be
um the Russians do attack civilian
targets directly always have done
because this is that is part of their
War Doctrine the ukrainians are adopting
Western ways of warfare and they've got
to stick to that well that's a really
important principle of Western Warfare
well let's talk more about the
escalation that we're seeing and how far
it might go at an army cave asks this uh
do Russian ground forces have the
capability to conduct Warfare in a
nuclear environment interesting question
of this in the event that Putin uses a
tactical nuclear weapons so yeah I mean
how do you use what you know what is
what is a tactical nuclear weapon what
effect does it have and can your own
forces remain immune from The Fallout uh
well no they can't
um so if nuclear weapons are used on the
battlefield and tactical nuclear weapon
it's nothing to do with the size of the
weapon as such it's to do with how it is
used so tactical nuclear weapon is is
for use on the battlefield and of course
they used to say in Germany in the in
the Cold War a tactical nuclear war in
Germany would just be the same as a
strategic nuclear strike you know if we
ended up in a in a nuclear exchange with
Russia it wouldn't matter who won or
lost it would feel as if we'd all lost
because of the concentration of people
in an area that would have been affected
now Ukraine is different because it's a
physically big country and if the
Russians were ever to use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine one of them would
make no difference whatsoever they would
have to use a number of tactical nuclear
weapons to make any Battlefield
difference and those weapons would have
to be getting on for Hiroshima size
weapons right so
Hiroshima was 15 kilotons that's a
Nagasaki about the same 15 16 kilotons
if you if the Russians wanted to
neutralize I.E kill say 3 000 Ukrainian
troops who were foolish enough all to
congregate in a in a place they've taken
like a criminal if they take cremina and
then they all hang around there then the
Russians would need to drop something
like a 10 kiloton air burst that would
probably kill three thousand and maybe
injure another six or seven thousand so
you'd actually neutralize say 10 000
civilians and Military in that case and
that would have dealt with criminal one
place in the battle at the moment in for
uh luhan's realistically the Russians
would have to use a handful half a dozen
Hiroshima sized bombs or something close
to a Hiroshima size bombs to have any
military effect and if Putin's going to
cross that threshold well then he'll be
subject to what I call the Everlasting
Judgment of History well there's a
there's an obvious question which I'm
sure all our viewers are wondering let's
let lindos put it to what would the
West's likely react B to a nuclear
strike well by Russia we've heard from
General you haven't reformally heard of
the the CIA that there would be a
conventional response he says that all
the targets that they could see in
Ukraine would be taken out mainly by the
United States yeah that's what he says
and whether General Petraeus is speaking
as it were on behalf of the Pentagon
because he is very well connected he's
you know he's he's one of the best
strategic thinkers in the United States
still in retirement
um and um I don't know if that's the
official American view but it's entirely
plausible and what we understand when
the the tactical nuclear weapon threat
sort of raised its head again a couple
of weeks ago the United States and some
NATO members and I'm sure we were one of
them but three or four NATO members
personally contacted their counterparts
in Russia and in the Russian general
staff to say don't even think about it
because and what they seem to have been
saying they don't tell us what they said
nor should they because there's got to
be some uncertainty about this in order
to maintain a sense of deterrence but
what they seem to have said is first for
we will not be passive we won't just
condemn you we will do a lot about it
secondly we will not go nuclear but we
will will sure as heck go conventional
and we have the conventional power to
hit all of your nuclear infrastructure
facilities and interestingly if we even
think that you're going nuclear if we
see the preparation starting remember
there's a long firing chain in Russia
for tactical nuclear weapons they have
they've got to do quite a lot to get
missiles and Warheads together in a
place where they can use them or
aircraft flying from Russia that can
drop something if we even see you making
these preparations we might attack you
that seems to have been the message now
I don't know conventionally or with you
conventionally conventionally
um now I don't know if that's what they
said but there's a general belief that
that's what they said and that the NATO
is is making it clear that you know you
will cross a big big line if not not
just a moral line but you'll cross a
line where we will take you on as a
military power by conventional means and
if you can live with risks of that and
the certainty that you will lose a great
deal of your military infrastructure in
our response then go ahead we are
getting closer what's the 60th
anniversary isn't it of the Cuban
Missile uh yes end of this month 26 27th
and 28th of the month I say that because
um Suzanne yeah has got this question
Let's uh do some comparisons with
history is this war similar to any other
conflicts over the last 50 to 100 years
if it is how did that previous conflict
end and could it provide lessons on how
to end this one what can you tell us
Michael what can he say well all
conflicts are different of course I mean
at the risk of sounding like a broken
record I mean this is like the conflicts
of the night of the 20th century or the
the conflicts against the fascists
Powers I mean Japan invaded Manchuria in
1931 on spurious historical grounds
because they wanted to take Manchurian
territory they thought it belonged to
them and then they extended it to the
whole of China in 1936 and while that
was happening Germany you know took uh
United with Austria in the Angelus in
1936 then took the sudeten land of
Czechoslovakia in 1938 then the rest of
Czechoslovakia in 1939 then invaded
Poland in the end of 1939 and not to be
outdone Italy invaded abyssinia in 1935
to recreate some sort of Roman Empire
and then invaded Albania in 1939 all on
spurious so genetic historical grounds
and so this that's why when we talk
about Putin looking like Hitler it's
always dangerous to bring Hitler into
arguments about this but to be honest in
this case the parallels are quite creepy
they're quite quite quite striking
and I mean this is a this is a 21st
century war of 20th century imperialism
this is a power that is decided wants to
conquer territories outside of its legal
recognized borders for spurious
historical reasons with it with a with a
crazy
misunderstood version of their own
history the history of Russia the
history of the Slavs the 21st century
weapons uh and of course you mentioned
we were talking there earlier weren't we
about a potential response from NATO
should tactical nuclear weapons be used
by Russia what happens though if we
haven't got enough Norman poses this
question our Western countries not in
danger now supplying so much of their
weapons stockpile that they'll be left
needing supplies themselves oh we're
beginning to run out we're hearing about
production difficulty already yeah
already we uh the fact is we've given
Ukraine very I mean a lot of our stocks
we gave them all of our in-laws the this
the anti-tank weapon that made a big
difference in the Battle of Kiev back in
Feb every March we gave them everything
we had and we're trying to restock now
and I mean the suppliers I mean people
like Saab in the case of the end laws
they've not been used to supplying big
numbers even in the states I mean
Northrop
um and uh Boeing they've been used to
supplying numbers of tens and twenties
um every year of these things as
Replacements and and uh you know as some
go off the off the end of the of the of
the sell-by date as it were
um now we're they're asking for hundreds
of these things and so Western defense
Industries cannot cope and we're into
this very interesting and difficult
situation where we want to give
ukrainians everything that they need in
high numbers and we are depleting our
own stocks there's big arguments going
on in Germany about whether they should
leave this leave themselves with nothing
to give Ukraine material and there's a
bit of politics behind that argument as
well we're more gung-ho about it we sort
of give them everything and we we will
find ways of restocking but it isn't
just a question of finding the money for
the stocks the manufacturers now are
doing very small amounts of most things
and so this is the tip of an iceberg and
the rest of the iceberg is that this is
the return of industrial Warfare to
Europe right this is the we've seen
Warfare the last 30 or 40 years is
Warfare of fragmentation small Wars wars
of choice Wars we didn't really have to
go to unless we thought there was
something important about it this is the
return of industrial War whoever
prevails in this war ultimately will be
the the side that can deploy its
industrial capacity properly now the
Russians will are trying to do that the
ukrainians need us to do it on their
behalf and we're only half realizing
that at the moment well let's end this
discussion with the big geopolitical
question and indeed back to that
question about how all might end this
from Adam will China and India bring an
end to the war by condemning Russia or
is there a view in places like China and
India that let the West Slug It Out with
Russia and exhaust themselves and we can
pick up the global pieces the the view
in China was not so much let them
exhaust themselves but let the Russians
diminish NATO further let them prove how
hopeless the Americans are let them show
that the the the the West Europeans are
not a a power or not a group of powers
to be reckoned with that was the that
seemed to be the Chinese view of course
it's gone wrong because the West has
stood up to this war much more so than
anybody thought the West would include
in most of us and that's partly because
president zolenski went out on the
streets of Kiev on the day of the war
starting said I've not gone I'm here
we're all here and the fact that he was
prepared to fight and put his life on
his own life on the line a lot of time
that that first week he was nearly
killed a few times and that fact changed
the nature of the war that zielinski
said I'm here and Biden said okay we
will we will support you we'll Supply
you and that's created the war that
we've got and in that respect it's gone
very very wrong for Xi Jinping of China
so can you bring it in to thought yes he
can if he withdrew support and he's he
himself doesn't want to withdrawal
support because he's friend he's a
friend we saw at that Summit didn't we
that's right last month when when both
in China it seemed to be slightly
correct Putin the Shanghai Corporation
organization and and uh Xi Jinping of
China was obviously critical Modi said
we can't carry on with this war erdogan
of Turkey said uh you've got to look for
peace and even the minor players
Kyrgyzstan Tajikistan they humiliated
Putin they actually kept him waiting
nobody would have dared to do that a
year ago but they all kept him waiting
because you can see this man's power his
political power is draining away if XI
jinping's pulled the plug pulls the plug
on him then I think that he's got
absolutely nowhere else to go and I
think then he would fall then he would
be removed because that would be a
complete disaster for Russia I don't
know that Xi Jinping is going to pull a
plug on him but but she has got his 20th
party Congress this month and we'll see
how he emerges from now he won't do
anything until that's over but when he's
got his third term we'll see what what
he does uh early next year Michael I'm
sorry I got to pull the plug on you
fascinating conversation as ever